a local news roundup with Conan O'Brien
and Andy Richter
[Applause]
[Music]
where were you Andy I was looking for
news yeah
speaking of which tonight's top story
budget cuts for Alaskan school buses led
to this a man picked up a snake and it
bit me
and it hurt a lot and the reporter at
the gun range had this to say Andy a
hybrid version of David Crosby in The
Big Lebowski participated in a spelling
bee auxotrophic and anchorwoman
Elizabeth Irwin named for two favorite
things tampons and vodka
next your local news ran a commercial
that made the always fatal mistake of
using rap to sell pets only one place
where fish and lizards hanging out with
X and chinchilla
keep back with hamsters and all erica
kravid cents or beyond and now Andy
Richter has sports thanks Conan in
sports your team's coach had a
revelation and says we gotta win games
and we have to get better we gotta win
games and we have to get better and now
with the weather here's Andy Richter
thank you Andy giant red arrows are
attacking in Mexico and the entire LA
coastline is covered in pepto-bismol
Conan
finally your local news had bloopers and
technical errors like this one I'm
against your pants and this one Ashley
testing one two three test Ashley you're
on Ashley I don't know if you can hear
me or not and my favorite this one the
problems with the gas line were mostly
fixed around 4:00 yesterday afternoon
workers were able to check most homes by
7:00 last night
they say all workers were required to
leave a note behind it's really dry they
have to enter the home and lock the door
as their left and that was your local
news roundup with Conan O'Brien and Andy
Richter